Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的内容之前，我想先告诉大家一个令人兴奋的消息。如果你曾想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“Race to Recurring Revenue”挑战。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是准心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up today, what is burnout and how might you know if you were experiencing it?
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由Lisa亲自提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一的辅导机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。今天的内容是：什么是职业倦怠？如果你正经历它，该如何察觉？
Over the summer, we are taking a deep dive into this fascinating topic of burnout so that you can be better supported in your journey as a mental health professional. This is such an important topic and it will benefit all areas of your life, including work, family and friendships too. I think you're going to find it to be completely indispensable. Hope you find it really useful. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. Now, for those of you who have been in my world for a while, you will know that I have shown up week after week after week because I am here for you. This is your compassionate, safe space. This is your place of complete, unconditional,
整个夏天，我们将深入探讨“职业倦怠”这个引人入胜的话题，以便让你作为心理健康专业人士在职业道路上获得更好的支持。这是一个非常重要的话题，它将造福你生活的方方面面，包括工作、家庭和友谊。我认为你会发现它不可或缺。希望你觉得它非常有用。你好，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家》播客。我是Marianne Trent博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。对于那些关注我已久的朋友，你们会知道我每周都会如约而至，因为我在这里是为了支持你们。这是你们充满同情心、安全的空间。这是你们获得完全、无条件、
positive regard to quote Rogers. But you know, it can be hard to fit this weekly event in over the summer holidays. And last year, you might recall we had the Summer Soundbites series. This year, we have Burnout Bites, which is going to be extra special because it is being guest hosted for us by the incredible Dr. Claire Plumley. This is not a guide just for the summer. This is for every day, every week of the year. So whenever you're listening to this, I think you're going to find it to be so interesting, so nourishing, and so helpful. You're going to get practical tips
积极关注的地方，引用罗杰斯的话来说。但你知道，在暑假期间要保持每周的更新可能很困难。去年，你们可能还记得我们有“夏季短语”系列。今年，我们推出了“倦怠小贴士”（Burnout Bites），它将格外特别，因为我们邀请了出色的Claire Plumley博士担任客座主持。这不仅仅是一份暑期指南，它适用于一年中的每一天、每一周。所以无论你何时收听，我相信你都会觉得它非常有趣、有益且实用。你将获得实用的建议，
to help you to recognize what it is that are going to be really, really useful for you as a person, but also for those that you work with and those around you too. It's just going to be the best thing. And because it does take me so long to record, edit and get all of this uploaded, I have given myself the summer off. And so we've got this all in the can before the summer begins.
帮助你认识到什么对你个人，以及对你共事的人和周围的人真正有用。这绝对会是最棒的内容。而且因为录制、剪辑和上传所有这些内容需要很长时间，我给自己放了个暑假。所以我们在夏天开始之前就已经把这些内容全部准备好了。
So it frees me up to spend more time mindfully with my family whilst also running my clinic. But it was important to me to still show up for you and to help you to move towards your goals, whatever they might be. You definitely don't need to be an aspiring psychologist or mental health professional to find these episodes a real, real help. Whoever you are, humans can absolutely experience burnout. And so you are welcome, however you stumbled upon us. And I and Claire both hope that you will find it to be time well spent. So with no further ado, let's dive in. Let's meet Claire and get on with episode number one. I will catch you on the other side. Hi, just want to welcome along our guest and too soon to be host of the podcast for a short period of time Dr Claire Plumley. Hi Claire. Hello yes I'm just so grateful that you're going to give me your
这让我可以更从容地陪伴家人，同时经营我的诊所。但对我来说，继续为你提供支持并帮助你实现目标（无论目标是什么）依然很重要。你绝对不需要成为一名准心理学家或心理健康专业人士才能从这些节目中获益。无论你是谁，人类绝对都有可能经历职业倦怠。所以，无论你是如何偶然发现我们的，我们都欢迎你。我和Claire都希望你能觉得这段时间花得很值。那么，废话不多说，让我们开始吧。让我们来认识一下Claire，并进入第一集。稍后见。嗨，我想欢迎我们的嘉宾，也是即将担任播客短期主持人的Claire Plumley博士。你好，Claire。你好，是的，我非常感激你能把你的
baby your podcast baby for a few weeks. Thank you. Thank you thanks for the idea I mean you know I know that it's going to be in very safe hands. But this came about as a result of trying to get you booked in for a session to do, you know, a chat about burnout for the podcast. And it sort of just developed quite naturally, as I said, oh, last year over the summer, I did a series of smaller episodes. And you were like, oh, well, you know, maybe we were both like, should you maybe do those and do it as an anti-burnout season? So thanks for being open to new and exciting opportunities. Yeah, no, it's been great. And I had a little thing about what to call them. We decided burnout bites because it kind of had the dual meaning, like burnout can bite, but also short nuggets so they're only like brief episodes um but hopefully each one just delivers like quick quick value or packs a
宝贝，你的播客宝贝交给我几周。谢谢。谢谢，谢谢你的点子，我是说，我知道它会得到很好的照顾。但这源于我试图为你预约一个时间，来为播客做一个关于职业倦怠的聊天。它就这样自然而然地发展起来了，就像我说的，去年夏天我做了一系列较短的节目。然后你说，哦，也许我们俩都觉得，你是不是可以做这些，把它作为一个“反倦怠”季？所以谢谢你对新的、令人兴奋的机会持开放态度。是的，这太棒了。我稍微想了一下该叫它们什么。我们决定叫“倦怠小贴士”，因为它有一种双重含义，职业倦怠会“咬人”（带来痛苦），但同时也是简短的“小块”内容，所以它们只是简短的节目，但希望每一集都能提供快速的价值，或者
bit of a punch uh so a little take home for each thing um and yeah so we've already I've already recorded those and that was my first experience of just talking in a podcast where I don't have anyone to talk to uh so that's been a bit of a learning curve for me I felt so awkward and I've you know I shared a few with you didn't I and you were like okay why don't you um say try those again so I just came across like some sort of wooden doll um so I'm hoping that um they're a little more amenable now you've warmed up beautifully I think by the time you kind of finished I think episode three well oh right now we're on to the stride why don't we just pop back and have another look at those but you know it is it does take effort and it does take time to allow yourself to grow as a podcaster I'm a much better podcaster now you know two and a half years in than I was when I started but even then I was used to talking to myself because I
带来一点冲击力，每一集都有一个小小的收获。是的，我已经录制了这些，那是我第一次尝试在没有对话者的情况下对着播客说话，所以对我来说这是一个学习曲线。我感到非常尴尬，我分享了一些给你，对吧？你说，好吧，你为什么不……再试一次？我当时听起来就像个木偶，所以我希望……它们现在听起来自然多了。我想当你录到第三集的时候，你已经表现得非常好了。哦，好吧，现在我们已经进入状态了，为什么我们不回头再看看那些内容呢？但你知道，作为一名播客主，让自己成长确实需要努力和时间。我现在比刚开始时好多了，虽然已经两年半了，但即使在那时，我也习惯了自言自语，因为
did lots of kind of free five-day challenges and things so it's a definite art um that you can craft and yes you are growing by the minute as well so tell us a little bit about you you are a qualified clinical psychologist yes um yes so I qualified in 2008 so yeah probably have over 20 years experience now mental health which sounds like a lot um and worked for several years in an Islington IAP service um did that for almost seven years and then went and spent almost three years in the Havens in London which is a sexual assault referral centre um and then moved to Somerset in 2017 um and at that point I set up in my private practice um amongst all of that had three children and um I did my EMDR training kind of started that off at the sexual assault referral center
我做了很多五天的免费挑战之类的活动。所以这绝对是一门艺术，你可以去打磨它，是的，你也在每分钟成长。那么，给我们介绍一下你自己吧，你是一位合格的临床心理学家，对吧？是的，我在2008年获得了资格，所以是的，在心理健康领域可能有超过20年的经验了，这听起来很多。我在Islington的IAP服务部门工作了几年，做了近七年，然后又在伦敦的Havens（一个性侵犯转介中心）工作了近三年，之后在2017年搬到了萨默塞特。在那时，我建立了我的私人诊所，在此期间生了三个孩子，并且我在性侵犯转介中心开始了我的EMDR培训，
um and then carried on and so now I'm also uh an EMDR consultant supervisor so I've kind of chipped away at that because I love that model um so yeah my main models I'd say are EMDR compassionate mind therapy um and like a lot of therapists interweave TPT skills, a bit of ACT, a bit of traditional CBT and mindfulness. You kind of gather these tools so that when you're faced with complexity, you've got something extra in your toolkit. And part of my experience working with trauma has been to get more familiar with the polyvagal theory, which is why I thought, actually, this is a useful um approach to understanding the nervous system why recently I decided to put my knowledge in in wisdom that feels a bit tricky using that word and expertise um into a book and so yeah that's what I've got my copy here but I'verored. So I don't know if you want to hold your copy up for anyone watching.
然后继续深造，所以现在我也是一名EMDR咨询督导。我一直在钻研这个领域，因为我热爱那个模型。所以是的，我的主要模型是EMDR、同情心聚焦疗法（CFT），以及像许多治疗师一样，融合了TPT技能、一点ACT（接纳承诺疗法）、一点传统的CBT（认知行为疗法）和正念。你收集这些工具，这样当你面对复杂情况时，你的工具箱里就有额外的东西。我处理创伤的部分经验是更熟悉多迷走神经理论，这就是为什么我认为，实际上，这是一种理解神经系统的有用方法。最近我决定把我所学的知识和智慧——用这个词感觉有点棘手——以及专业知识写成一本书。所以是的，我这里有我的副本，但我把它弄乱了。所以我不知道你是否想为观众举起你的副本。
So, yeah, it's called Burnout, How to Manage Your Nervous System Before It Manages You. And so, yes, about 20 years experience of that has gone into that. It's taken me about 18 months to complete as a project. And I'm really hoping that bringing a clinical psychologist lens to this topic will be helpful for people. Absolutely. And I know that we get lots of qualified as well as aspiring psychologists listening to this and people that are working in mental health professional fields or non-related fields trying to get kind of into psychology. psychology and any work stream has the capacity for burnout even even being a parent you know and not working has the capacity for burnout it's it's such a big topic it's such an important topic and I know this is something you also speak about on your social channels too so when people listen to this series of podcast episodes which you don't need to listen to in order you don't need to commit to all of them you can kind of duck in and out when they obviously love what you do
所以，是的，书名是《职业倦怠：在神经系统控制你之前如何管理它》。所以，是的，大约20年的经验都融入其中了。作为一个项目，我花了大约18个月才完成。我真的希望从临床心理学家的视角来探讨这个话题能对人们有所帮助。绝对是这样。我知道我们有很多合格的以及准心理学家在听这个节目，还有在心理健康专业领域工作的人，或者非相关领域但想进入心理学的人。心理学和任何工作流都有可能导致职业倦怠，甚至即使是作为一名父母，不工作也有可能导致职业倦怠。这是一个非常大的话题，一个非常重要的话题，我知道这也是你在社交媒体上谈论的话题。所以当人们收听这一系列播客节目时，他们不需要按顺序收听，不需要全部听完，他们可以随时进出。他们显然很喜欢你所做的事情。
where can they come and follow you on socials claire um yeah i do hang out on a few i'm a bit like you i like to kind of i get different things from different channels um so particularly enjoy connecting with other professionals on instagram so that's's at Dr. Claire Plumley. Um, I tend to put out lots of TikToks, um, and not all my TikToks make it onto Instagram. So if you are on TikTok, do go and follow me there. Cause I think TikTok allows a bit more of a, a raw kind of feel to the videos. I like to be a bit more curated on Instagram. Um, and yeah, I've been using LinkedIn a little bit more recently, just having a play around more with words because that invites more kind of clever use of words, doesn't it? So I think I just enjoy socials for the kind of freedom and creativity.
他们可以在哪里关注你的社交媒体呢，Claire？嗯，是的，我在几个平台上都有活动。我有点像你，我喜欢……我从不同的渠道获得不同的东西。所以我特别喜欢在Instagram上与其他专业人士联系，账号是@Dr. Claire Plumley。我倾向于发布很多TikTok视频，而且并非我所有的TikTok视频都会同步到Instagram。所以如果你在用TikTok，一定要去那里关注我。因为我认为TikTok允许视频有一种更原始的感觉。我喜欢在Instagram上更精选一些。而且，是的，我最近在LinkedIn上用得更多一些，只是在玩弄文字，因为那邀请人们更巧妙地使用文字，不是吗？所以我认为我只是享受社交媒体带来的自由和创造力。
I don't know if you found that, but it really has been helpful, especially in my line of work where it's a lot of heavy trauma to kind of bring a bit of lightness and diversity into my week yeah absolutely I would totally concur that there's a different vibe a different kind of different feel to the different channels and the um you know it depends what I've got capacity for as to where I'm hanging out hanging out the most I would say yeah thank you so much for running with this project and doing it so beautifully um I will look forward to handing back over at the end of the summer but yeah thank you and thank you hope your book baby flies for you just remind us when it's being published uh so it's out on the 18th of july um so by the time this airs maybe it's already just come out so yeah do you go grab a book um learn all about how um polyvagal theory and compassionate mind therapy and act on all these kind of models that
我不知道你是否也有同感，但这真的很有帮助，特别是在我的工作中，有很多沉重的创伤，能给我的周带来一点轻松和多样性。是的，绝对的，我完全同意，不同的渠道有不同的氛围，不同的感觉。而且，你知道，这取决于我有什么精力去决定我在哪里花的时间最多。是的，非常感谢你承担这个项目并做得如此出色。我期待着在夏天结束时接手回来，但是的，谢谢你，也希望你的“书宝宝”能大卖。提醒我们一下它什么时候出版？嗯，它在7月18日出版，所以当这期节目播出时，也许它已经刚上市了。所以，是的，去买一本书吧，了解多迷走神经理论、同情心聚焦疗法、ACT以及所有这些我们
we know and already love can support people and yourself maybe with burnout perfect where can people grab that is that the usual amazon waterstones yeah exactly yep all those places all good bookshops um and please do leave a review if you find it helpful as well so others can find it and know it might be the right book for them absolutely and there will be links in the show notes for all of this. So with no further ado, let me pass my podcast baby over to you so that you can guide us through episode one, thinking about what is burnout. Thank you. Thanks, Marianne, for the introduction and for lending me your seat in the Aspiring Psychologist podcast for the summer. I'm so delighted to be here and bring everybody my burnout bites. So these are short episodes standalone that are going to tell you
了解并已经喜爱的模型如何支持他人，也许还有你自己应对职业倦怠。太棒了，人们可以在哪里买到它？是通常的亚马逊、Waterstones吗？是的，完全正确，所有那些地方，所有好的书店。如果你觉得它有帮助，也请留下评论，这样其他人也能找到它，并知道它可能是一本适合他们的书。绝对的，节目说明里会有所有这些的链接。那么，废话不多说，让我把我的播客宝贝交给你，这样你就可以引导我们进入第一集，思考什么是职业倦怠。谢谢。谢谢Marianne的介绍，也谢谢你把《有抱负的心理学家》播客的席位借给我过夏天。我很高兴能来到这里，为大家带来我的“倦怠小贴士”。这些是简短的独立剧集，将告诉你
all about burnout and some top tips for protecting yourself as you journey towards becoming a psychologist or perhaps if you are already a qualified psychologist. So if you don't know me already I'm Dr. Claire Plumley. I'm a clinical psychologist and also a specialist in trauma anxiety and burnout and I have recently written a book. It's called Burnout How to Manage Your Nervous System Before It Manages You and it's available right now to buy on all the usual bookshop sites and you can find the link in the show notes. So very quickly, I'm going to run down what to expect in these burnout bites. There are six episodes and they're all about 10 minutes long.
关于职业倦怠的一切，以及在你成为心理学家的旅程中保护自己的一些顶级建议，或者如果你已经是一名合格的心理学家。所以如果你还不认识我，我是Claire Plumley博士。我是一名临床心理学家，也是创伤、焦虑和职业倦怠方面的专家，我最近写了一本书。书名是《职业倦怠：在神经系统控制你之前如何管理它》，现在可以在所有通常的书店网站上购买，你可以在节目说明中找到链接。所以很快，我将介绍在这些“倦怠小贴士”中可以期待什么。共有六集，每集大约10分钟长。
In today's one, I'm going to introduce you to what burnout actually is. A lot of us have an intuitive sense of burnout, but it's not something psychologists are taught about. So it's talked a lot in the occupational health arena and occupational psychologists and coaches always use this term much more confidently than other types of psychologists do. So I'm going to bring you the definition and a really quick assessment tool. So if you're listening to this kind of thinking, I don't know if I'm burned out or not, then make sure you stay to the end of this one. In the follow-up one, I'm going to talk about the difference between stress and burnout because even though those terms often used interchangeably they are actually different. I'm going to introduce you in the third one to the three subtypes of burnout. I personally found this really helpful to understand
在今天这一集中，我将向你介绍什么是职业倦怠。我们很多人对职业倦怠有一种直觉，但这不是心理学家在培训中被教导的内容。所以它在职业健康领域被谈论得很多，职业心理学家和教练总是比其他类型的心理学家更自信地使用这个术语。所以我将为你带来定义和一个非常快速的评估工具。所以如果你听着这些，心里在想，我不知道我是否倦怠了，那么一定要听到最后。在后续的一集中，我将谈论压力和职业倦怠之间的区别，因为尽管这些术语经常互换使用，但它们实际上是不同的。在第三集中，我将向你介绍职业倦怠的三种亚型。我个人发现这对于理解非常有帮助，
because it's not a one size fits all kind of difficulty. So I personally found that I oscillate between the different ones depending on what's going on and it can be helpful to know what they are. In the following episode I will give you a stage model of burnout. There are a few different stage models but the one I draw on in my book and that I'm going to give to you in one of these burnout bites is a five stage model. Stay for that one if you think you'd like to know where in the stage model you might be or anyone you're working with might be and what the different interventions might look like depending on that. Following that we've got a burnout bite all about pacing and transition points in the day so this is going to
因为它不是一种“一刀切”的困难。所以我个人发现，根据正在发生的事情，我在不同的类型之间摇摆，知道它们是什么会有所帮助。在下一集中，我将给你一个职业倦怠的阶段模型。有几种不同的阶段模型，但我书中所引用的，以及我将在这些“倦怠小贴士”中给你的，是一个五阶段模型。如果你想知道你可能处于阶段模型的哪个位置，或者你共事的人可能处于哪个位置，以及根据这些阶段，不同的干预措施可能是什么样的，请留下来听那一集。接下来，我们有一个关于节奏和一天中过渡点的“倦怠小贴士”，所以这将是
be about how to care for yourself if you feel like you're starting to move up the stages of burnout or perhaps have already reached it. And then in the last episode, I'm going to talk about the difference between internal and external pressures. I think external pressures get a lot of airtime. This is all about the demands that are put on us and they are really important and there are a lot of demands. But there are also internal pressures which psychologists particularly clinical psychologists often work within the therapy room and so I'm going to talk about the three patterns that I also describe in my book and you can watch out for this in yourself and also in your clients. So I do hope these six episodes will be helpful to you. Let's get started right now about what
关于如果你觉得你开始进入职业倦怠的阶段，或者可能已经达到这个阶段，该如何照顾自己。然后在最后一集中，我将谈论内部压力和外部压力之间的区别。我认为外部压力得到了很多关注。这都是关于施加在我们身上的要求，它们确实很重要，而且要求很多。但也有内部压力，心理学家，特别是临床心理学家，经常在治疗室里处理这些问题，所以我将谈论我在书中描述的三种模式，你可以在自己身上以及你的客户身上留意这些模式。所以我确实希望这六集对你有帮助。让我们现在就开始吧，关于什么是
actually burnout is so the official definition and how to recognise the telltale signs in yourself. So let me explain a bit about what burnout actually is. So a lot of people think of exhaustion when they consider burnout. And that's absolutely right. Exhaustion is an important aspect of burnout. But there are three different parts to burnout. Exhaustion is only one. It's important to say that it's not a mental health diagnosis. It is considered a syndrome according to the World
职业倦怠，官方定义以及如何在自己身上识别出明显的迹象。那么让我解释一下什么是职业倦怠。很多人在考虑职业倦怠时会想到精疲力竭。这绝对是对的。精疲力竭是职业倦怠的一个重要方面。但职业倦怠有三个不同的部分。精疲力竭只是其中之一。重要的是要说它不是一种心理健康诊断。根据世界卫生组织和ICD-11，它被认为是一种综合征，
Health Organization and the ICD-11 but it's not in the DSM. Syndrome means that there is a collection of difficulties all presenting alongside each other and they tend to kind of come up in this pattern so that's the difference. So I'm going to run through those three in a minute. But one important comment about the official who definition is this. They define it as an occupational phenomenon, a set of difficulties that arise in an unmanaged chronic workplace stress type of situation. And part of the difficulty with this is that we often interpret work as meaning paid work. So the difficulty then is that the experience of millions of unpaid people go unrecognized. Parents, informal carers, students, all these people often use this word burnout as well. And it's now that research and measures are starting to be developed
但它不在DSM中。综合征意味着有一系列困难同时出现，它们往往以这种模式出现，这就是区别。所以我一会儿会讲这三点。但关于世卫组织官方定义的一个重要评论是：他们将其定义为一种职业现象，即在管理不善的慢性工作场所压力情况下出现的一系列困难。而这其中的困难部分在于，我们经常将“工作”解释为“有偿工作”。因此，困难在于数百万无偿工作者的经历未得到认可。父母、非正式护理人员、学生，所有这些人也经常使用“职业倦怠”这个词。现在研究和衡量标准开始为
for all of these groups, as well as the more occupational paid type of burnout that we've traditionally kind of used that term to describe. So it's an important time to know about burnout. And I think so it's really helpful to know this term burnout, and to be aware that lots of people really find it a helpful, useful way of describing what they're going through and managed chronic stress due to work can happen in many different environments paid informal unpaid so what are the three different categories we've already started talking about exhaustion this is physical and emotional exhaustion this is often when people feel really wrung out perhaps they've just gone and gone until they can really go no more and yet they still keep on
所有这些群体开发，而不仅仅是传统的职业有偿类型的职业倦怠。所以现在是了解职业倦怠的重要时刻。我认为了解“职业倦怠”这个术语非常有帮助，并意识到很多人确实发现这是一种描述他们所经历的事情的有用方式。由于工作导致的慢性压力管理不善可能发生在许多不同的环境中，有偿的、非正式的、无偿的。那么我们已经开始谈论的三种不同类别是什么？精疲力竭，这是身体和情感上的精疲力竭。这通常是人们感到非常枯竭的时候，也许他们只是不停地工作，直到他们真的无法再工作，但他们仍然继续
pushing through and the result is that they just feel hollow they might feel like they've not got their full repertoire of emotions you know joy and happiness maybe they're just feeling irritable and grumpy or really cynical and feeling like nobody cares about me and it's hard for me to care about others actually at this point and this leads us on to the second one, which is this real depersonalization and disconnection. This is when we are often on autopilot. We might get an experience of brain fog, might feel really distanced from others or like we're zoning out. And the third one is reduced personal accomplishment. This is when you might feel like, oh, I'm just a rubbish therapist or I'm a rubbish parent or a rubbish friend we often put ourselves down we might have low self-esteem imposter syndrome
强迫自己，结果就是他们感到空虚。他们可能觉得自己的情绪储备不足，你知道，快乐和幸福，也许他们只是感到易怒、脾气暴躁，或者非常愤世嫉俗，觉得“没人关心我”，而且此时此刻我很难关心别人。这引出了第二个，即真正的去人格化和疏离感。这是我们经常处于自动驾驶状态的时候。我们可能会有脑雾的体验，可能会感到与他人非常疏远，或者像是在“神游”。第三个是个人成就感降低。这是当你可能觉得，哦，我只是一个糟糕的治疗师，或者一个糟糕的父母，或者一个糟糕的朋友。我们经常贬低自己，我们可能有低自尊、冒名顶替综合征，
you might feel like nothing you do is really good enough and it might be also if you are kind of experiencing this in the context of the other two categories of burnout that you are actually kind of coasting and cutting corners doing your job not properly just getting by in a way that maybe you never used to and this can feel like then you are really misaligned with your values and how you really would like to be doing your work so this definition and these categories come from work done by Christina Maslach in the 70s and 80s she's really the one who brought this definition to the public and made it very well known as a concept burnout. And for anyone who's a little bit interested in some of her backstory, she was actually married to Philip Zimbardo. And if you remember, he's the one who did the Stanford prison experiment.
你可能觉得你所做的一切都不够好。如果你在其他两类职业倦怠的背景下经历这种情况，你可能实际上是在“混日子”，偷工减料，工作做得不专业，只是以一种你以前从未有过的方式勉强应付。这会让你觉得你与自己的价值观以及你真正想做的工作方式严重不符。所以这个定义和这些类别来自Christina Maslach在70年代和80年代所做的工作。她确实是将这个定义带给公众并使其作为一个概念广为人知的人。对于任何对她的一些背景故事有点兴趣的人来说，她实际上嫁给了Philip Zimbardo。如果你还记得，他就是做斯坦福监狱实验的那个人。
So the story goes that she actually was invited to see and observe some of this prison experiment. This was the one where young men were invited as participants to be either prison guards or prisoners during the time when they were exploring social influence and conformity. And she turned up and witnessed how the prison guards were acting towards the prisoners and recognised this kind of depersonalisation, being less emotionally attached to the people in their care. And this is partly why the prison experiment was brought to a close earlier than Zimbardo had intended. And it's also thought to have been fairly instrumental in the early days of Christina Maslach's work into her own burnout research and work. Let's think about the effects of this on us because often I think that's when people turn up
故事是这样的，她实际上被邀请去观看和观察这个监狱实验。这是一个邀请年轻人作为参与者，在探索社会影响和从众心理期间担任监狱看守或囚犯的实验。她去了，目睹了监狱看守对待囚犯的方式，并认识到了这种去人格化，即对他们照顾的人情感上不那么依恋。这就是为什么监狱实验比Zimbardo预期的更早结束的部分原因。这也据信在Christina Maslach早期对她自己的职业倦怠研究和工作产生了相当大的影响。让我们思考一下这对我们的影响，因为通常我认为这就是人们寻求
for therapy or start to kind of see that things can't go on. So obviously the effects are going to be on things like sleep. So struggling to fall asleep, we talk about feeling. For me personally, I tend to find I start having early morning waking where my body's almost just like adrenaline starts pumping earlier in the day than I really want it to. You might get escapism thoughts, like thoughts about how can I get out of all of this stress. So for me, I often notice when I'm moving down this burnout path, I start to get more thoughts of like, if only I could get ill, if only I could break a leg or something, an arm or something that wouldn't mean I'm out of action for too long, but just enough to escape all of this heaviness and busyness. You might also become more socially withdrawn. So you're starting to say no to things that usually you would enjoy doing.
治疗或开始意识到事情无法继续下去的时候。所以很明显，影响会出现在睡眠等方面。所以难以入睡，我们谈论的是感觉。对我个人来说，我倾向于发现我开始出现清晨醒来的情况，我的身体几乎就像肾上腺素在一天中比我真正想要的时间更早开始泵送。你可能会有逃避主义的想法，比如关于我如何摆脱所有这些压力的想法。所以对我来说，当我沿着职业倦怠的道路走下去时，我经常注意到我开始有更多的想法，比如，如果我能生病就好了，如果我能摔断腿或什么东西，胳膊或什么东西，那并不意味着我长期无法行动，但足以逃避所有这些沉重和忙碌。你可能也会变得更加社交退缩。所以你开始拒绝那些你通常喜欢做的事情。
Maybe your phone messages are backing up. This is definitely a telltale sign for me where lots of people have contacted me. I keep thinking, oh yeah, I'll get to that eventually. And then I'm just not getting around to it. And I feel very disconnected, no idea really what's going on in my friends' lives. You might also notice your intentions to self-care around food or exercise fall off the wagon. So healthy eating and doing anything that moves your body. These are the things that we know will help us. But at the of most need we tend to really struggle to do you might also find like the quick fix responses show up like you know scrolling on social media turning to have a drink and for me I find the impulse shopping happens it's not so much clothes
也许你的手机信息堆积如山。这对我来说绝对是一个明显的迹象，很多人联系了我。我一直想，哦，是的，我最终会处理的。然后我就是没时间处理。我感到非常疏离，真的不知道朋友们的生活中发生了什么。你可能还会注意到你在饮食或锻炼方面的自我保健意图“掉链子”了。所以健康饮食和做任何能活动身体的事情。这些是我们知道会有帮助的事情。但在最需要的时候，我们往往真的很难做到。你可能还会发现像“快速修复”的反应出现，比如，你知道，在社交媒体上刷屏，转而去喝一杯。对我来说，我发现冲动购物发生了，这对我来说不是衣服，
for me it will be those adverts springing up on social media that promise some sort of answer so usually some sort of online course and which I never get around to watching and suddenly my bank balance is like dropping because I'm spending money on quite quick courses and workshops pre-recorded which just adds to the overwhelm because I don't have time to watch them so I hope some of this is helpful maybe started to help you to think about your own little moments of overwhelm so I hope this is helpful for you to start thinking about your maybe telltale signs of burnout. But let me just add quickly that there is a single measure of burnout that you might find helpful. It's quite a quick one and it has been validated against the Maslap burnout inventory
而是那些在社交媒体上弹出的广告，承诺某种答案，所以通常是某种在线课程，我从来没时间看，突然我的银行余额就像在下降，因为我花钱买了一些相当快速的课程和研讨会，预先录制的，这只会增加负担，因为我没时间看它们。所以我希望其中一些是有帮助的，也许开始帮助你思考你自己的一点点不堪重负的时刻。所以我希望这对你开始思考你可能出现的职业倦怠迹象有帮助。但让我快速补充一点，有一个单一的职业倦怠衡量标准，你可能会觉得有帮助。它相当快，并且已经根据Maslach职业倦怠量表进行了验证。
as well. So here is the question. Overall, based on your understanding of burnout, how would you rate your level of burnout? And there are five ratings. Let me run through them. Rating one, I enjoy my work. I have no symptoms of burnout. Two, occasionally I am under stress and I don't always have as much energy as I once did, but I don't feel burned out. Three, I'm definitely burning out and I have one or more symptoms of burnout such as physical and emotional exhaustion. Rating four, the symptoms of burnout that I'm experiencing won't go away. I think about frustration at work a lot. Rating four, the symptoms of burnouts that I'm experiencing won't go away. I think about frustration at work a lot. And finally, rating five, I feel completely burned out and I often wonder if I can go away. I think about frustration at work a lot. And finally rating
所以问题是这样的。总的来说，基于你对职业倦怠的理解，你会如何评价你的职业倦怠程度？有五个等级。让我过一遍。等级一，我享受我的工作。我没有职业倦怠的症状。二，偶尔我处于压力之下，我并不总是像以前那样有精力，但我不觉得倦怠。三，我绝对在倦怠，我有一种或多种职业倦怠的症状，例如身体和情感上的精疲力竭。等级四，我正在经历的职业倦怠症状不会消失。我经常想到工作中的挫折感。等级四，我正在经历的职业倦怠症状不会消失。我经常想到工作中的挫折感。最后，等级五，我感到完全倦怠，我经常想我是否能……我经常想到工作中的挫折感。最后等级
five, I feel completely burned out and I often wonder if I can go on. I'm at the point where I may need some changes or some sort of help. So if you score a three or more, this does indicate that you are burned out. This means change is needed. If if this sounds like you then one invitation is for you to listen to these six episodes of burnout bites as a starting point but of course you can also go and get more immediate support in the form of my book or one-to-one therapy thank you so much for joining me in my first episode of burnout bites i really hope you'll come and join me in the second one where i'm going to explain the difference between stress and burnout. I'll see you then. Oh, what an absolute pleasure. And even I feel like I've learned more about what burnout is. And so
五，我感到完全倦怠，我经常想我是否能坚持下去。我已经到了可能需要一些改变或某种帮助的地步。所以如果你得分在三或以上，这确实表明你已经倦怠了。这意味着需要改变。如果这听起来像你，那么一个邀请是让你听这六集“倦怠小贴士”作为起点，但当然你也可以通过我的书或一对一治疗获得更直接的支持。非常感谢你加入我的第一集“倦怠小贴士”，我真的希望你会来加入我的第二集，在那里我将解释压力和职业倦怠之间的区别。到时见。哦，真是太荣幸了。甚至我觉得我也学到了更多关于什么是职业倦怠的知识。所以
as Claire said, this isn't something that's necessarily spoken about on clinical training. So I think you're going to find this really useful, whoever you are. And I thank you for listening. I hope you're already looking forward to catching up with episode two. You don't need to listen to all of them. They are all standalone. To get the maximum benefit, it might well be useful for you to check out the series. Details in the show notes of how to get Claire's book, Burnout, how to manage your nervous Nervous System Before It Manages You, which is a brilliant read, then check out the details in my show notes or by clicking any of the links in my bios on social media where I am Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. You can also connect
正如Claire所说，这不是临床培训中必然会谈论的内容。所以我认为你会发现这非常有用，无论你是谁。我感谢你的收听。我希望你已经期待着收听第二集了。你不需要全部听完。它们都是独立的。为了获得最大的收益，查看整个系列可能对你很有用。节目说明中有关于如何获得Claire的书《职业倦怠：在神经系统控制你之前如何管理它》的详细信息，这是一本精彩的读物，然后查看我节目说明中的详细信息，或者点击我社交媒体简介中的任何链接，我在那里到处都是Dr. Marianne Trent。你也可以联系
with and follow Dr. Claire Plumley. If you are enjoying this episode, I would love it if you consider following the show or subscribing if you're watching on YouTube following and subscribing is just the best free gift you can give to any podcaster and if you're watching on Spotify or YouTube please do drop a comment if you're listening on Apple podcast please take a moment to rate the show and you can drop a review on there too when you listen from your podcast app on your iPhone. Come and let me know what you think to this episode in the aspiring psychologist community with Dr. Marianne Trent and don't forget the books The Clinical Psychologist Collective and
并关注Claire Plumley博士。如果你喜欢这一集，如果你考虑关注这个节目，或者如果你在YouTube上观看的话订阅它，我会很高兴。关注和订阅是你可以给任何播客主最好的免费礼物。如果你在Spotify或YouTube上观看，请务必发表评论。如果你在Apple Podcast上收听，请花点时间给节目评分，当你从iPhone上的播客应用程序收听时，你也可以在那里留下评论。来Dr. Marianne Trent的“有抱负的心理学家”社区告诉我你对这一集的看法，别忘了这些书《临床心理学家集体》和
The Aspiring Psychologist Collective and if it's your time and you're ready for the next step and you really want to maximize your chances of avoiding burnout and having a really successful year in psychology, why not consider joining us in the Aspiring Psychologist membership, which you can do for just £30 a month with no minimum term. Thank you so much for being in my world. Thank you so much also for allowing Claire to so generously step into our world. I know that you'll make her feel incredibly welcome too. Stay kind to yourselves. Let's practice what we preach and make sure that we are thriving, not just surviving. The next episode of the podcast is available on YouTube from 10am on Saturday and wherever you get your podcasts from 6am on Monday. Take care. I'll see you very soon. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psych collective book I found it really interesting
《有抱负的心理学家集体》。如果时机成熟，你准备好迈出下一步，并且你真的想最大限度地提高避免职业倦怠并在心理学领域度过非常成功的一年的机会，为什么不考虑加入我们的“有抱负的心理学家”会员计划呢？你只需每月支付30英镑，没有最低期限。非常感谢你进入我的世界。也非常感谢你如此慷慨地让Claire进入我们的世界。我知道你也会让她感到非常受欢迎。保持善待自己。让我们践行我们所宣扬的，确保我们是在蓬勃发展，而不仅仅是生存。播客的下一集将于周六上午10点在YouTube上发布，并于周一上午6点在你获取播客的任何地方发布。保重。很快再见。我叫Jana，我是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书，我发现它非常有趣，
about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家，这让我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以到达那里，而且没有成为心理学家的完美方式。这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，只是为了让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。